Write the conditional
statement in if-then form.
And the statement is,
dogs have four legs, which
we know is true.
So another way of
thinking about it,
you say, well, if you have a dog
or if an animal is a dog then
it's going to have four legs.
That's an equivalent
statement to this here.
So let's see if we can
construct a sentence like that.
So if an animal is a dog
then it has four legs.
So that was pretty
straightforward.
Let's do a few more of these.
So here, same thing.
We want to write this
as in if-then form,
I will win a gold medal
when I go to the Olympics.
So let's see.
This is essentially saying,
if I go to the Olympics
then I will win a gold medal.
So if I go to the Olympics
then I win a gold medal.
Now, you might be tempted
to say, hey, well,
I saw gold medal first here
then I saw Olympics later
in the sentence, but
this isn't saying
that if you win a
gold medal then you
have gone to the Olympics or
then you will go the Olympics.
You might win a gold medal
at the local track meet
or something, and
that's not going
to ensure that you're
going to the Olympics.
This is saying that if
you go the Olympics--
this person is very
confident who is ever
saying this-- I will
win a gold medal when
I go to the Olympics.
So that's the same
statement as saying,
if I go to the Olympics, I'm
going to win a gold medal.
So if I go to the Olympics
then I win a gold medal.
And actually, this
statement is a little bit
more confident than this
one because here they say,
if I go to the Olympics
while here they
say when I go to the Olympics.
But I think you get the idea.
Let's do a couple more of these.
I will go to Disneyland
when I win a gold medal.
So now, winning
the gold medal is
what's driving stuff to happen.
So if I win a gold medal
then I will go to Disneyland.
then I go to Disneyland.
Oh, that wasn't right.
Oh, I didn't put this.
I go to Disneyland.
I got too careless.
I got to make sure I do
if I win a gold medal then
I go to Disneyland.
And now we got it right.
Let's do one more.
I can't do enough of these.
These are incredibly fun.
Isosceles triangles
have two equal sides.
So if I have an
isosceles triangle
then I have two equal sides.
So if a shape is an
isosceles triangle
then it has two equal sides.
And we got it right.